Let's create a new app
using Android Studio.
We'll create a basic Android application
that has a single empty activity.
I'm just going to call it Location1,
and it's in this location.
The company domain,
you can put whatever you like.
I'm just going to keep
that Android.example.com.
I'm going to make it a Jelly Bean
application for phone and tablet's.
And like I said earlier, it's
going to be a single blank activity.
I'll keep the defaults and continue.
Now once this has been created,
I'm going to edit the activity
to add a single text view.
When you run the app, location services
will start getting updates and
it will write details about
them to this text view.
To edit the text view in the activity
editor, just select the Text tab and
you can see what your
layout would look like.
So, here's the basic layout
that has been built for
you in the default in Android Studio.
You can see, it already has
a text view and the text for
this is held in a string refered to
in strings.xml called hello world.
I'm just going to change that
to something hardcoded for now.
I'll just say location goes here and
then I'm going to give
this control an ID.
So, I'm going to give
it the ID like this,
android:id=@+ID/txtOutput.
So when I refer to this control
in code in a few moments,
you will see that the control
will be called txtOutput.
So this control is where the location
is going to get written.
So when we get details from
location services, in this case,
the latitude of the phone, we'll write
it into this control called txtOutput.
And if I look at the design,
you can see location goes here.
It's faint, but
you can see it's there in this one.